John 52223 in the Jo Witness
Bible okay for the father judges no one
at all but he's entrusted all the
judging to the son so that all may honor
the son just as they honor the father
whoever does not honor the son does not
honor the father who sent him God bless
you Lopez okay did you catch it now
let's see if you're gonna catch it now
why did I quote this passage why did I
quote this passage from the Joe vitness
Bible the reason why I quoted John 52223
specifically 22 to show that Jesus our
lord said the father judges no one at
all but is entrusted all the judging to
the son let's look at it again John
5:22 for the father judges no one at all
but has usted all the judging to the son
that's why I quoted the verse Jesus says
my father doesn't judge anyone he's left
it to me to judge everyone you need the
Joe witness to get to see that you're
going to have to say do you see Joe
witness Jesus said the father is not the
one who's going to be judging anyone do
you agree that is Jesus who's going to
be given all judgment to judge everyone
yes make sure they agree so it's the son
right the son is going to be judging
everyone yes not the father right yes
that's the first point Matthew 16:27
Matthew
16:27 for the son of man is to come in
the glory of his father with his angels
and then he will repay each one
according to his behavior why am I
quoting this because Jesus is speaking
saying I the son of man will come in the
glory of my father God is his father
showing the son of man the Son of God
with my angels and I will
repay I will repay
each one according to his behavior okay
so according to Jesus who's coming to
repay everyone according to their
behavior Jesus right not the father
According To
Jesus will the Father Judge anyone or it
is the son who judges everyone and the
father has given all judgment to the
son okay so if you got that let's go to
revelation 22:12
look I am coming quickly and the reward
I give is with me toay each one
according to his word according to what
we read who's speaking here who's saying
look I'm coming quickly the reward I
give is with me to repay each one
according to his work who's speaking
here according to what you just read in
Matthew and
John right okay praise the Lord you're
getting it to further prove is Jesus
Revelation 222 and 20 12 and 20 let's
connect them together Revelation 2212
and 20 look I am coming quickly I am
coming quickly one more time I am coming
quickly don't forget that that phrasing
and the reward is I give is with me to
repay each one according to his work now
verse 20 the one who Bears witness of
these things says yes I am coming
quickly yes I am coming quickly amen
come Lord Jesus come Lord Jesus did you
get it so who's saying look I am coming
quickly and the reward my reward is with
me to repay each one according to his
doing yes I'm coming quickly amen come
Lord
Jesus okay are you sure you're getting
it because this is how you're going to
do with the Jehovah Witness this is how
you're going to do it with the Jehovah
Witness
okay now this is what we're going to do
Matthew
16:27 back to back with Revelation 2212
and 20 Matthew 16:27 back to back with
Revelation 2212 and 20 for the son of
man is to come in the glory of his
father with his angels the son of man
come in the glory of his father with his
angels and then he will repay each one
according to his behavior revelation
22:12 look I am coming quickly and the
reward I give is with me to repay each
one according to his work verse 20 the
one who Bears witness of these things
says yes I'm coming quickly amen come
Lord Jesus okay now why did I repeat
myself and yell and scream and because
here's why then you go to revelation 22
Now read 20 12 and 13 here's why all of
this was to do this Revelation 22: 12-
13 look I coming quickly and the Lord I
is with me to P1 according to his work I
am the Alpha and the Omega the first and
last the beginning and the end bam end
of story Jo Witnesses get you a new
religion who just said I'm the alpha and
omega the first last the beginning and
the end
Jesus you thank you no no no Manuel you
didn't get it Jesus is Jehovah but
you're right for JE witness Jehovah is
the father I get what you're saying
Jesus is jeh but he's not the father so
for joov witness Jehovah is the father
yep exactly but I got what you
mean you see how I did
it because then they can't deny it if
you follow that approach John
5:22 Matthew 16:27 to get them to see
and admit yeah Jesus is the one who
judges not the father Jesus is the one
who's coming to pay each one according
to their doing not the
father Revelation 22:12 look I'm coming
quickly and the reward I give is with me
repay each one according to his deed
who's that Jesus verse 13 I'm the alpha
and omega the first last beginning the
end bye-bye Jo
witness no in the Old Testament doesn't
use beginning the end he uses first last
but they have a way around
that they have a way around the first
last that's why I didn't go into that
it's going to take too much time to
unpack I stuck with that which can't get
around because if you ask them who's the
Alpha and Omega they'll say Jehovah
meaning the father can a creature be
Alpha Omega they'll say no only Jehovah
the Father the father who is Jehovah
only he can be Alpha and
Omega you know why they they can't allow
a creature to be Alpha and Omega you
know why they cannot allow for a
creature to be Alpha and Omega and allow
for Jesus to be ala because they think
he's a creature because go to revelation
21: 6 to 7 Revelation 216 to7 and he
said to me they have come to pass I'm
the alpha and omega the beginning the
end to anyone thirsting I will give from
the spring of the Waters of Life free
anyone conquering will inherit these
things and I will be as God he'll be my
son see this is why they can't allow
Jesus whom they think is a creature to
be Alpha and Omega because here it says
the one who claims to be Alpha and Omega
meinian says I will be his God I will be
his God he'll be my son so they know
this has to be almighty God
speaking it didn't sink
in the sink
in so they'll admit only God only
Jehovah can say I'm alpha and omega
beginning and the end but then you got
Jesus saying alpha and omega beginning
the end first and last first last
beginning the end now why is it the case
that only God Almighty can say Alpha and
Omega first last beginning the end
because you have to explain what the
titles mean you know what those titles
mean Alpha and Omega are the first and
last letters of the Greek alphabet it's
like saying in English I am a and z i Am
A and Z a is the start the beginning of
the alphabet Z is the end the last
letter of the alphabet so that means
Alpha and Omega is simply another way of
saying beginning the end first and last
if you're the first and last you're the
beginning and the end if you're the
beginning the end you're the a and z
alpha and omega if you're Alpha and
Omega you're the first and last these
are simply three titles that say the
same thing
right so do you understand what it means
Alpha and Omega first last begin end I
am the beginning I am the end I am the
first I am the last I am the A and the Z
what that means
is God has been there from the beginning
of creation from the very first creature
creatures and he will continue to
be with all creatures throughout all
generations till the last generation to
the very end of the age this is simply a
way of saying that God because he's
uncreated Timeless who created all
creation created time space and place
was there from the start of creation and
continues to remain with creation till
the very end of the age because he's not
bound to time he's Timeless he's
Sovereign over time he's the god of time
overseas time and everything that takes
place in it that's why a creature cannot
claim these
titles that's why a creature cannot
titles okay now everyone understand that
argument we got it now it's down pth
down
path how it irrefutably points to Jesus
Jesus Christ in their own
Bible and for Jesus Christ to say he's
alpha and omega beginning the end first
and last that cannot be said of a
creature no creature can claim that but
Jesus Christ did because he's no
creature he is the Eternal son Almighty
one with the father and the Holy
Spirit so he's not the father he's not
the spirit but they're the one God and
as the one God he's Almighty uncreated
Timeless he was there from the start
he's with us till till this day and will
remain to the very end of the age with
every subsequent generation of creatures
and Believers until he ushers in the new
heaven new Earth okay now let me just
put some icing on the cake on it go to
Revelation 21 verses 6
to7 one more
time the Jo Witness Bible Revelation 21:
6 to7 and he said to me they have come
to pass I'm the alpha and omega the
beginning the end to anyone thirsting I
will give from the spring of the Water
of Life free I will do that who's going
to do it the Alpha and Omega the
beginning end will give those who
believe in him to drink from the spring
of the Water of Life anyone conquering
will inherit these things and I'll be
his God he will be my son so guys catch
it the one who's the alpha omega
beginning the end who's the god of those
who conquer and we are as children he
will give those who conquer the right to
drink from the spring of the Water of
Life here it says God okay Revelation
7:17 who gives us the right to drink
from the spring of the Water of Life for
free Revelation
7:17 because the lamb who's in the midst
of the throne will Shepherd them and
will guide them to Springs of waters of
life and God will wipe out every tear
from their eyes did you catch it the
lamb will bring us his flock to Springs
of waters of life but in Revelation 216
to7 it said The God Who is the Alpha and
Omega in beginning end he will do that
he will bring you to the spring of the
Water of Life to drink freely Revelation
7:17 it's the lamb who does
it you caught it